good evening welcome I'm Kirk
Freudenberg chair of the department of
classics here at Yale and it's my honor
and delight to welcome all of you to the
third annual and Emory and Adam Carey
lecture before I introduce tonight's
speaker I'd like to do two things first
I'd like to ask you all to please snuff
out all cell phones and electronic
devices deftly and second I'd like to
take just a little bit of time to talk
about the series to which tonight's
lecture belongs started just two years
back the series aims to highlight the
work of scholars of ancient literature
who excel in the methods and talents
that were once so beautifully
exemplified by an Emory and Adam Terry
the thoughtful and detailed analysis of
Greek and Latin texts as well as the
further receptions of those texts in
ways that are at once adventurous
elegantly written and critically
informed the Bingham library is the
right place for this lecture you can see
their pictures right there on the wall
it houses the books that once belonged
to n a Murray and Adam Perry as well as
the PhD dissertations of just some of
the many students whom the dynamic
husband and wife pair would have worked
with in the late 60s and early 70s
before meeting their tragic and
simultaneously simultaneous end in the
motorcycle accident of 1971 both Adam
and Ann were leading scholars of Homer
and Homeric criticism as well as the
study of other ancient texts especially
facilities in Virgil it is in the spirit
of their wide-ranging elegantly written
an exciting scholarship that we invited
Joseph Rousseau a proud former colleague
and protege of both in a Marine
Perrie to give the inaugural lecture two
years ago and it was with equal
commitment to that spirit that we asked
Gordon Braden one of the world's leading
scholars of Renaissance literature PhD
Yale 1975 to give the Perry lecture last
year tonight we have the pleasure of
welcoming Ellen all the answers I'm
gonna call you Ellen revenue Nelly for
the purposes of the introduction
welcoming her to the stage Ellen fits
the bill of this lecture beautifully a
professor of classics at the University
of California Berkeley
Ellen can deal with our lousy spring
weather here in New Haven because she is
a Yale a several times over she took her
BA in literature summa [ __ ] laude here at
Yale in 1981 before heading off to do a
PhD in confident at Harvard from there
to Princeton for a year of teaching in
classics and humanities and then to
Harvard for a three-year stint at the
Harvard Society of fellows in 1992 she
returned to Yale first as an assistant
than associate professor in classics and
humanities and then in 1999 she followed
the warm Zephyrs back to Berkeley where
she quickly established herself as a key
member of one of the most outstanding
classics programs in the country her
daughter is now finishing her freshman
year here at Yale wave to us she's back
there somewhere okay Rebecca I think
right Ellen first came to my attention
as a Horatius scholar first by way of
what is now a classic article on the
erotic of horses epics then with a
magnificent first book forest and the
rhetoric of authority which appeared
from Cambridge in 1998 the book explores
how Horace's poems all of them satire
zeppelins epistles ODEs construct the
literary and social authority of their
author it talks that poetic persona I
not just as rhetorical acts
stylizations that do important cultural
work responding to the demands put on
poets to look certain ways at certain
times as social acts playing to multiple
audiences it's fantastic book just as
important today as the day of first
appeared and like everything Ellen all
ANSYS is published it shows just how
much meaning is there to be had from the
small details in the tix and terms and
colors of any given snippet of Latin
poetry she's extremely good at this that
same brilliant penchant for teasing out
the bigger hidden context from what's
there before us in the complex habits of
ancient Latin is put on bright display
in Ellen's most recent book Freud's Rome
psychoanalysis in Latin poetry which
came out from Cambridge in 2009 this is
a book that doesn't just talk about
repressed things bubbling up to the
surface it shows that effort there it
shows that effort to not quite manage to
repress in action in a fantastic series
of case studies from catalyst Virgil and
Ovid to my mind Freud's room is the best
book out there on its chosen topic
certainly but it is also the best book
out there on catalyst and it doesn't
actually purport to be a book on
catalyst Ellen's take on the Apple
tumbling from the guilty girl's lap and
from taller 65 is itself worth the price
of the book nor is it technically
speaking a book about of it and yet it
manages to be the best study of the
songs of Orpheus and Ovid's
metamorphoses that you'll be able to
find and so on but I need to leave it at
that and let professor Alianza speak for
herself since that's why we're all here
we will have time for questions after
the talk and we definitely want to
encourage an active post lecture Q&A and
we have a nice reception waiting for us
and here I need to think this is a
co-sponsored lecture with the department
of comparative literature
you have David Quint up front along with
Dudley Andrews and we want to thank them
and exemplify our wonderful cooperation
in this event for now please join me in
welcoming professor Eleanor ANSYS will
talk to us this evening on the topic of
the authorial perversion did the desire
for discourse in Ovid's amorous thank
you so that was the nicest introduction
I've ever ever had it was all for the
benefit of my child I'm sure right thank
you so much I'm really gratified by the
invitation it's a huge honor to you know
speak for the Perry lecture it's also
very nice to be back at Yale and it's
hard to believe that just a few years
ago I was a freshman you know like a few
floors down seriously I was in this very
entryway of DIMM yeah more than a few
years ago I snuck into this library once
or twice but it was not actually easy to
get access to so I feel good being here
can you all hear me back there cuz I'm
trying to avoid a microphone and I feel
like I'm it's okay okay well so this
paper I'm currently working on of and
pretty much all the time and this paper
it is sort of some material from the
last chapter of a current book on Ovid's
Amore's that is kind of nearing
completion I hope so
there's a lot of stuff that comes before
but I don't think you need it for the
purposes of this talk in the other thing
I would just say is that there is a
handout but it is really unnecessary
I think classicists always have to have
handouts or it's just not a classics
talk but you could actually listen to
this my goal is to have this talk be
listenable and comprehensible without a
handout at all so I just say I also I'm
not gonna flag things on the handout you
know don't worry about the handout it's
there if you want to look at it but you
don't need to alright so it is an old
chestnut of the scholarship on love
poetry that the lover has to suffer so
the author can succeed though there do
exist poems celebrating erotic
fulfillment these are the exceptions
that prove the rule satisfied lovers
being no more the stuff of poetry than
happy families at fiction after all if
the lover regularly succeeded he would
have no occasion to plead
Rawal threaten or complain that is he
would have no occasion to produce the
erotic discourse which constitutes the
fame of the author whose name he shares
thus it is really the case that the
sufferings of the lover are the delight
of the author and this is true even if
the author happens to be authentically
in love and actually suffering the
torments of unrequited desire since in
his authorial capacity he cannot but
capitalize on the distress of the
character who represents him within the
erotic fiction this is a truth however
that love poetry is deeply committed to
obfuscating indeed it is probably not an
exaggeration to say that love poetry
grows on the grave in which this truth
lies buried the protagonist of love
poetry doesn't share the author's
enthusiasm for suffering he doesn't
embrace frustration because it provides
opportunities for first making on the
contrary he makes verses one way or
another to allay his distress this
foundational fiction is neatly
encapsulated in the catalan phrase
orator at loquitur the lover is on fire
and he speaks that is the lover is on
fire and therefore speaks one of the
most notorious features of the Amore's
is the insouciance with which Ovid
discards this fiction it is not just
that the avidians lover is an
incorrigible womanizer whose rhetoric is
transparently insincere but that the
supposed sufferings of this lover are
disclosed from the first as nothing more
than grist for the authorial mill in a
mores one one avid tells us that he was
all set to write an epic poem when cupid
intervened and abruptly terminated his
epic career arms and savage Wars was i
preparing and weighty metre to produce
with the matter match in the form the
lower line was equal to the upper cupid
laughed they say and snatched away one
foot
what makes this opening so witty and so
shocking is not the mere fact that when
the curtain rises on this collection of
love poems the poet is not in love it is
the fact that Cupid intervenes not by
making him fall in love but by attacking
his meter leaving him with elegiac
couplets on his heads and nothing to
fill them with as the irate poet after
roundly rebuking the mischievous God for
meddling in the affairs of
amuses himself observes besides I don't
have any material suitable for lighter
measures no boy or girl with well
quaffed tresses this is a problem Cupid
can and promptly does solve by shooting
an arrow through off its heart thereby
making him burn albeit as yet for no one
in particular
but the damage as far as the conventions
of the genre are concerned is already
done here is a love poet who instead of
writing because he is in love falls in
love so that he will have something to
write about scholars come at the Amore's
from many different perspectives
feminist historicist formalist and they
speak with many different voices but on
one point they are practically unanimous
what the peculiar origin myth of the
Amore's discloses is that Ovid is
writing not love elegy as such but elegy
at one remove a project of
disenchantment that scholars variously
characterized as a savage parody or
brilliant pastiche or clear-sighted
demystification or mere encyclopedic
compendium of the conventions of his
chosen genre the most extreme
articulation of this position I have
encountered is served up by Ralph
Johnson in the introduction to his 2009
book on pre-purchase I quote as for Ovid
who came at the tail end of the elegant
project his love poems glittering with
flawless technique and polished to a
durable Sheen by ruthless irony
concerned themselves mostly with
cataloguing as for a museum exhibit the
prime themes and tactics of love elegy
and with displaying them as a sort of
gaudy collection of outworn cliches
Johnson's rhetoric may be extreme but
his emphasis on the in authenticity of
the amorous is absolutely representative
indeed I think it is fair to say that
for most classicists today the amorous
have no erotic content at all or at
least none that is given to us
immediately if there is desire in the
Amore's it is so to speak mentioned
rather than used the only scholar I know
who takes the desire of the amore
seriously is Philip Hardy who opens his
suggestive pages on the collection with
an astute appreciation of a vidiian
vacuity proposing that quote the
emptiness and unreality of the avidians
object and quote the written esophageal
scenes a narratives of desire so far
from being the symptoms of frivolity and
detachment are rather signs of a
searching engagement with the structures
and dynamics of desire for Hardy the
essential revelation of the amores is
that the frustration of our desire to
know karena not only follows from her
status as a merely textual being but
also points toward a larger truth the
unavailability to desire of the woman in
her real presence forever screened from
our eyes by a fetishistic textual
substitute in effect what Hardy does
here is to show the psychoanalytic
implications of the dominant line on the
amores the absence of any semblance of a
realistic love object has its own
realism in that it corresponds to a
desire that is itself founded on
irreducible absence Hardy's reading is
predicated on the assumption that what
the lover desires what we all desire is
the real presence of Corinna and that
the textual surface of the Amore's is
the substitute with which we have to
make do in the absence of that presence
while I am a huge fan of Hardy's
scholarship the argument of this paper
stems from my conviction that such an
assumption does not do justice either to
desire or to the Amore's or to the
pleasures explored ad afforded by the
Amore's the most effective antidote to
the impoverished account of sexuality
that dominates scholarship on the
Amore's is provided by Freud's three
essays on sexuality
popular opinion freud writes on the
first page at the first essay has quite
definite ideas about the nature and
characteristics of the sexual drive it
is generally understood to be absent and
childhood to set it at the time of
puberty and to be revealed in the
manifestations of an irresistible
attraction exercised by one sex upon the
other while its aim is presumed to be
sexual union or at all events actions
leading in that direction even
twenty-first century readers may be
taken aback by the Trenton Sea of the
Freudian rejection we have every reason
to believe that these views give a very
false picture of the true situation
according to Freud the sexual drive does
not come bundled with a particular
object Hatteras
sexual adult human and aim genital
intercourse on the contrary he argues a
very little reflection surfaces to real
reveal that the sexual drive and the
sexual object are merely merely soldered
together and that the sexual aim is
easily hijacked even in purportedly
normal people by various forms of what
Freud calls perversion for AI classifies
these as on the one hand extensions of
sexual interest beyond the genitals own
this is where freud locates the over
valuations of romantic love and on the
other lingering or fixations at
preliminary or normally subordinate
activities such as touching and looking
the road to normative genital
heterosexuality is just one of a network
of available paths and it is really a
miracle that so many arrives safely at
the socially approved destination now
perversion carries implications of
deviance abnormality and so on but that
is not at all how I mean the word in
this paper my understanding of
perversion derives from the work of Jean
Laplace who on the basis especially
approach three essays argues that for
Freud sexuality is in essence nothing
but perversion la plage takes as his
starting point for roids observation
that sexual excitation can arise as a
marginal effect in the case of a great
number of internal processes to take a
classic example for the baby the
necessary action of Nursing which
supplies food for life also engenders as
a marginal effect the autoerotic
pleasures of sucking pleasures which
then take on their own life independent
of hunger and the mother's breast in
felicitous in one respect and that it
fails to bring in milk the infants
intransitive sucking is a source of
felicity and another register nor I want
to underscore does this register derive
its value from any nostalgic
recollection of the missing milk
sexuality happens somewhere else and no
amount of milk will do it any good
unless milk has crossed over an editor
to the sphere of fantasy in the process
ceasing to beef just milk this is why la
plage can describes sexuality in its
entirety as quote the slight deviation
the Clennon from the function and this
is why he argues that sexuality is
always already
is constituted by and as perversion the
perversion of need into desire or as
Lapage puts it the perversion of the
vital function bisexuality late in the
second essay Freud suggested sexuality
can arise from any disruption any
agitation of the organism physical or
mental once it reaches a certain level
of intensity and concludes it may well
be that nothing of considerable
importance can occur in the organism
without contributing some component to
the excitation of the sexual drive it is
partly on the basis of this claim that
Laplace and following Laplace Leia
Bersani locates the primordial agitation
of masochism at the very heart of human
sexuality and I should say masochism is
the subject of the previous chapters not
this one the teleological model of
desire the model that yields the default
assumption that the avidians desire has
or should have one object
corinna and one aim sexual union is an
ideological imposition on the real
waywardness of sexuality it is this
waywardness I am convinced that Ovid's a
mores perform and that constitutes the
central attraction of this body of
poetry if not for scholars whose
enthusiasm for the collection has always
been somewhat muted then for the
innumerable readers who have taken
pleasure in the Amore's over the
centuries this waywardness extends
beyond the narrowly sexual and
encompasses what we might term Ovid's
stylistic promiscuity already in
antiquity Ovid was notorious for his
lack of aesthetic discipline his
virility his rampant exuberance Seneca
the elder censured the leek entia of his
poetic diction and added that far from
being unaware of the flaws in his poems
he absolutely cherished them Seneca the
younger
likewise criticized Ovid for ruining his
sublime description of the flood by
adding the ludicrous images of wolves
and lions paddling in the waves fooling
around says Seneca the verb is Lasky
we're a when the whole world has been
swallowed up quintillion is also severe
on the subject of Ovid style on two
separate occasions faulting the
metamorphosis for loss Cahuilla and
observing that Ovid was too much in love
with his own
it seems to me the professor famously
lamented that Ovid's tragedy Medea shows
how he might have excelled had he
preferred to rule his genius rather than
to give it free rein these critics focus
on off its epic meta morphosis
because the conventional sobriety of the
epic genre renders his stylistic
excesses especially egregious but what
interests me here is how precisely their
strictures suit the Amore's in
particular a case in point is a mores -
for this is a poem that opens with Ovid
acknowledging his faulty character
claiming to be wracked by self-hatred
and lamenting his lack of self mastery
is like a rudderless ship at the mercy
of winds and waves what follows this
self indictment and purportedly explains
it is a lengthy and perfectly cheerful
catalogue of the vast array of female
types who solicit Ava's desire tall and
short or Beynon uncouth blond and
brunette and so on and on and on
commenting on this poem Joan booth
remarks nowhere does Ovid write with
more wit and ingenuity and nowhere with
more fluency and grace and then adds yet
nowhere does he more invite Seneca the
elders famous criticism that he never
knew when to stop Lasky Weah a term that
encompasses not just a vice of style but
all forms of irresponsible playfulness
the friskiness of young animals the
flirtatiousness of young people the
sexual provocations of lovers captures
both the promiscuous content and the
self-indulgent style of amorous - for
and indeed of the amorous as a whole
earlier I observed that in a morays 1:1
avid lays bare the foundational
divergence of interests that love poetry
is normally committed to occluding the
poet lover wants to have sex the author
wants to write poems but in fact Ovid
goes much further than this
what Ovid presents us with in the
Amore's is a poet lover and henceforth
to avoid confusion I will refer to him
as nazo who fully shares the author's
goal of proliferating discourse so it is
not the case that the lover of my race
has to suffer suffer so the author can
have his poems
on the contrary naso has to suffer so he
can get what he wants the agitating
pleasures of the middle space where
desire cohabits with discourse this is
what I am calling the authorial
perversion in the field of discourse as
of sexuality nassos perversion is one in
the same
it is the detachment of the drive from
its normative aim and the relocation of
pleasure within the act of discourse
nowhere is this detachment more directly
represented than in Amore's 219 the poem
that closes the second book this is the
poem in which NASA berate s' a husband
for failing to keep an eye on his wife
thereby making NASA's love life
intolerably easy scholars have often
wondered what this poem is doing at the
end of its book given that unlike the
poems that closed books 1 and 3 this
poem has no obvious programmatic content
and enters no proud claim of authorial
success yet the poem strikes me as very
well suited to its position within the
collection throughout this poem what
naso is trying to forestall is the end
or even the end this is why his closing
address to the doltish husband gives so
much play to the verb in kippa ray this
is on the handout somewhere as for you
who are so careless of your lovely
ladies start closing the door at
nightfall already start asking who's
furtively knocking so often at your door
and then again a little further down now
I'm warning you upfront if you don't
start guarding that girl of yours she'll
start to stop being mine Missy to serve
soiree puella Incubus in capilla de
sinner sa man the climax comes in the
next couple as naso spells out the
proper roles of husband and lover I've
put up with a lot for a long time I
hoped it would be a regular thing that
when you've done a good job of guarding
I do a good job of giving you words come
bene services but bene where ba Dharam
in Latin the phrase direct we're above
give words carries the idiomatic sense
of deceive or hoodwink but here it
carries something more than that in the
art of love
naso
excludes the rich lover from his
classroom on the grounds that a man who
is prepared to make gifts has no need of
my art while opening his doors to the
poor me I'm a poet for the penniless
since I was myself a penniless lover
when I couldn't give her a present I'd
give her words comb dine on possum moon
era we're about da bomb which I'd like
to translate as I'd hand her a line in
effect what NASA is gloomily
anticipating in a Moraes 2:19 is the
removal of the stimulus for the
production of elegiac lines this is why
in the very next couplet he is warning
that the end is nigh you're too pliable
you put up with things no husband should
as for me there will be an end to this
licensed loving at me he con Cassie
Venus amorous errand the poem concludes
with naso ordering the husband if he
wants to retain naso as his rival to be
obstructive may to be real all MCU uh si
wet ah the silence that follows this is
the last word of the book certainly
suggests that the husband has declined
to comply now it is true that a morays
2:19 is susceptible to a conventional
reading other poets may confess that
rivalry is the spice of love but none
discloses as blatantly as Ovid does here
the mechanism that keeps love allergy
going without some sort of obstacle to
overcome
where would elegy be the bizarre
scenario of a lover demanding more
vigilance from a lackadaisical husband
draws attention we might say to the
foundational divergence of interests I
flagged earlier the author wants to
write poems the protagonist wants sexual
gratification by staging their
impossible convergence the lovers
suffering is thus exposed as the
strictly generic requirement that it
really is this argument squares nicely
with the traditional reading of the
amorous as a demystifying critique of
love elegy what I'm advocating by
contrast is that we at least consider
taking naso at his word by recognizing
that the activity of Daria where be' is
not just a means to an end but erotic
Lee
rewarding in its own right and why
shouldn't it be so in an essay entitled
wrestling Sigmund Harold Bloom responds
to the account of the origins of
sexuality provided by Freud and Laplace
with a prolonged tragic sigh thus human
sexuality alas on this account has not
had from its very origins any real
object the only real object was milk
which belongs to the vital order
hence the sorrows and you know and the
authentic anguish of all human erotic
quest hopelessly seeking to rediscover
an object which never was the true
object anyway all human sexuality is
trop illogical
whereas we all of us desperately need
and longed for it to be literal it is
the alas and the anguish and the
hopelessly and the desperately that I am
aiming with the help of the besotted
wordsmith of the Amore's to contest why
should those of us who spend much of our
lives revolving words the ones we read
and the ones we write be so resistant to
acknowledging the substantial pleasures
they afford nas O's logo philia puts a
different spin on the theme of the
failure of rhetoric in the Amore's to
which Richard Terence some time ago and
more recently Myka Madson have drawn
attention the point is not just that
NASA's rhetoric though in principle it
could succeed does regularly fail that
nazo
never actually represents his couplets
charming open a door or cajoling a girl
into bed or persuading a rival to ease
up or conversely to get tough the point
is that NASA seems to take care to
ensure in advance that his rhetoric
cannot but fail sometimes he does this
by putting himself in impossible
situations as for example when he tries
to persuade dawn not to break or a
flooding River to subside at other times
it is not the situation but the approach
that is doomed in a Maurice 1:8 naso
represents himself overhearing Elena a
baaad or madam instructing his
girlfriend on the proper way to choose
and use a lover
the gist being that wealth should trump
everything including poetry
tell me says the bog what does that bar
of yours give you besides new poems now
there's a lover who will give you many
thousands to read two poems later it is
clear that his girlfriend has fully
absorbed the lesson and naso is
grappling with the challenge of winning
her favor without paying for it his
strategy is to climb on his high horse
venting his disgust at her mercenary
character and exalting the superior
value of deathless poetry my gift Hindi
merely reminds her is to honour
deserving girls in poetry
dresses tear jewels and gold break but
the glory granted by song will last
through the years that this is just a
tactic and a hopeless one at that is
clear from the backpedaling conclusion
that immediately follows it's not giving
but being done for cash that I resent
and despise what I refuse when you ask
stop wishing for it and I'll give but of
course there is no indication that naso
will make good on this promise which
remains suspended in the unrealized
future of Dabo against this backdrop I
can't help noticing that the very next
poem shows us na so once again trying to
score on the cheap this is the famous
poem in which and also asks Corinna's
slave nepai to deliver a letter to
Kareena asking for a date though naso
spends much of the first part of the
poem flattering na pay
evidently in the hopes of persuading her
to do her best on his behalf by the end
of the poem he seems to have forgotten
not pay altogether if the mission is
successful it is the writing tablets
nossos faithful servants and not the
faithful not pay who will be rewarded
for services rendered the slippage
between these two instruments of the
Masters desire the slave and the writing
tablets has been much discussed what
interests me here is what I will call
adopting Cathleen McCarthy's terminology
the story world implications of this
slippage as it happens in the course of
the lecture naso overheard an amorous
1-8 the bog suggested that a girl bent
on fleecing a rich lover would do well
to enlist the services of her entire
household her slaves for example can
tell her lover what presence he should
buy while also asking for a little
something on their own account and extra
something that the BOD indicates will go
to swell
household coffers given that not pay is
an on kill law in fact this is the only
other instance of the word ancilla and
Amore's one it is small wonder that the
mission not so and Trust to her ends in
failure leap everybody for my misfortune
the tablets have come back and morning
the letter says can't today though nah
so blames us out come on the accursed
materials of which the writing tablets
must have been constructed it seems more
likely that not pay failed him and
Corinna refused him because he put
nothing more tangible than poetry on the
table on the one hand we may decide that
this Fiasco is just more evidence of
nasa's blockheaded complacency on the
other hand it is true that his decision
to court not pay and Corinna was
sweet-talk and only with sweet talk
effectively ensures that the need for
verse remains as acute as ever it is
clear that na so is not incapable of
coughing up something other than
couplets when it suits him to do so
in Amore's 1:6 naso appears before us in
the classic posture of a locked out
lover alternately flattering
supplicating and haranguing the slave
who guards his girlfriend's door and yes
we are now on the second page interested
ok yeah as day approaches nah so finally
departs leaving his garland on the stoop
for his girlfriend to see a sign of his
fruitless vigil and also offering a
surprisingly generous tribute to the
unyielding doorkeeper first the garland
but you garland torn from my unhappy
head lie there all night on the hard
threshold when my girlfriend sees you
thrown there early in the morning you'll
bear witness to my misspent hours and
then the doorkeeper such as you are
goodbye then and feel the tribute I give
you as I go centi quoi Bayonne to Sonora
sorry Oh Noir is usually understood as a
reference to NASA's grudging praise of
the doorkeepers virtuous performance of
his duty which follows in the next line
stubborn man you who haven't disgraced
yourself by admitting a lover goodbye
but such a turn from lame to praise has
no parallel in the Amore's
and hardly suits nassos character as we
have come to know it the point I think
is not that the doorkeeper has shown his
independent resolved by withstanding
nassos verbal assault but that he has
played precisely the part he was
supposed to play the part na so needed
him to play so I suspect that in this
instance on or carries it's more
substantial sense of a pecuniary tribute
or tip alongside the garland the
departing na so leaves a little
something for the obliging doorkeeper
who has enabled him to spend the night
spinning couplets so though he won't pay
to gate gain access to the house he will
pay to have the doors securely locked
against him na Soze irrepressible desire
for discourse spills out in the poem to
Natha and sorry if you want to look it's
on the previous page here na so
vacillates between the demand for
rhetorical economy and the desire for
rhetorical elaboration writing as a
prelude to sex and writing as a
replacement for or even a form of sex it
is characteristic that NASA wants
Corinna to reply both at once and at
length lines 19 to 22 neck Mora
pair electives race creep at Volta
debate Oh order her without delay to
write a long answer I hate it when there
are blank spaces in the shiny wax let
her pack the lines in their ranks let my
eyes linger on letters scratched at the
very edge nossos desires spreads to
everything associated with Corinna
including the marks in the wax that
indicate the pressure and carried the
erotically charged metonymic trace of
her writing hand carving letters into
wax is an old figure for procreative
intercourse with a wax tablet
representing the blank female material
awaiting masculine inscription so there
is a double perversity in nasa's desire
for Corinna's writing a quantity of
verses as he calls them that holds up a
mirror to NASA's own prolix appeal after
indulging in this fantasy naso pulls
himself up short why should she wear out
her fingers holding the stylus let the
entire tablet
hold a single word come the minimal
reply naso is hoping to receive matches
the brevity of the oral message he
entrusted to not pay along with the
tablets is she asked me what I'm up to
tell her I live in hope of a night the
rest is on the wax marked by my coaxing
hand this quick exchange I'm living in
hope of a night so come would be the
pragmatic preamble to a sexual encounter
not its perversely elaborated discursive
replacement and in fact one imagines
NASA might have fared better on this
occasion had he forgone the
blandishments and restricted himself to
this minimal solicitation as Richard
Tarrant has pointed out throughout the
amorous and in fact throughout of its
work there is an inverse relation
between quantity and efficacy that is
the more naso talks the less he achieves
and vice-versa the limit case is the
famous sexual encounter of amorous
one-five an exceptional scene of erotic
success as tarrant remarks which unfolds
without a single word being spoken on
either side the point is driven home by
amorous 1:13 where naso is actually in
his girlfriend's arms when he composes
his doomed appeal to the goddess of the
dawn an elaborate oh bad that takes
place against the background of an
erotic coup that involved so far as nah
so let's on no persuasion at all the
single representation of possibly
successful erotic persuasion and the
amorous is the exception that proves the
rule
no mores to to naso addresses himself to
the severe eunuch who has been assigned
the task of watching over a girl who has
caught his eye what interests me here is
the contrast between nasa's long-winded
appeal the poem is in fact the longest
in its book and the embedded
representation of maximally efficient
communication that motivates that appeal
here are the opening lines of the poem
but Gois you who are charged with
watching over your mistress please give
me her attention while I go through a
few relevant points yesterday I saw a
girl strolling in the portico that has
the row of Dan ions since I liked her
looks
I immediately sent and asked for a date
meeseeks scripto quit rogue ah oui
with a trembling hand she wrote back
can't and when I asked why not the
reason she gives is your work some
watchfulness this rapid-fire exchange of
notes roughly how about it can't why not
that annoying slave sets the stage for
the full-scale rhetorical assault on
Bogost that follows the swass Oriya
proper as Macomb terms it but at the
same time it discloses as if it
advertently that naso is fully capable
of using language both efficiently and
effectively in some naso is not just
obliging of it by making opportunities
for vers naso does not fail just to
enable of it to succeed on the contrary
failure appears to be a non-negotiable
demand that naso himself imposes on his
own rhetoric I want to underscore that
Ovid didn't have to write the story this
way
a pair of poems from her purchases first
book of allergies and which propitious
first laments that Cynthia is going off
on a sea journey and that rejoices that
she has to come to his pleas and
cancelled her trip shows the
availability of an alternative the point
is not that naso never succeeds in
having sex on the contrary it is clear
that he very often does the point is
that those successes are never
associated with a successful rhetorical
appeal indeed the very possibility of
such an association is sometimes raised
only to be ostentatiously severed the
love letter that naso and trusts to not
pay fails to win him the night with
Corinna for which he was hoping yet in
the very next poem Amore's 1:13 there is
naso lolling about in bed
spinning his doomed plea to dawn having
enjoyed just such a night with a girl
who remains nameless and even more
pointed disjunction is produced in the
second book where na Solem bends
Corinna's decision to go off on a
journey and then in the very next poem
boasts exultant Lee of his amazing
victory Carina is in his arms it is
impossible not to
think of the pair of proportion poems to
which I just alluded but even readers
who have never read pre-purchase will
initially assume that the triumph is the
consequence of nassos persuasive
performance in the previous poem but in
fact naso makes it very clear that this
is not the case what he has overcome and
there is no indication in the poem that
his eloquence played any part is not
Carina's decision to go abroad but the
conventional obstacles the husband the
chaperone the locked door that prevent a
lover from gaining access to a woman
trapped within a domestic space so it is
almost as if NASA were fending off the
very possibility of rhetorical success
as if such a success would decisively
cancel the pleasure he takes in the
performance I'd like to end this paper
with a brief discussion of the poem that
opens the third and final book of
Amore's Amore's 3:1 most of which you'll
find reproduced on the handout between
the second and three pages there's a lot
of text there and I'm not going to talk
about all of it like amores 1:1 this
poem is a narrative retrospect but this
time when the curtain rises nazo is not
busy writing an epic or anything else
but wandering in a sacred grove
seemingly at loose ends looking he tells
us for a work for my muse to set in
motion quad may acquire a bomb Musa
molarity opus so it is true the husband
naso accused of criminal indifference at
the end of the previous book has not
mended his ways enter not one but two
applicants for the position of muse
fetching elegy dressed in silks with an
elegant quoi for and a seductive limp
and scowling tragedy in busken's and a
long mantle brandishing a sceptre in her
hand
though elegy enters first tragedy
overtakes her with violent strides and
seizes the initiative chastising NASA
for his scandalous goings-on and urging
him to abandon elegy for the grown-up
and manly genre represented by herself
next stepping between her poet and his
severe suitor elegy first acknowledges
tragedies superior gravitas and then
mounts a spirited defense of
own talents and services rendered and
the poem ends with NASA politely
postponing tragedy and committing
himself to one last book of elegy in
amorous one one cupid transformed naso
into a love poet the burden of a mores
3:1 however is not that desire
determines what the poet writes but that
writing is what he desires I can clarify
what I mean by this claim by setting it
against Maria wieck's influential work
on the elegiac mistress in wieck's
famous formulation this mistress is a
script puella a textual body that
incarnates her author's aesthetic and
ideological ambitions a mores 3:1 bulks
large and wieck's
argument because this is a poem
featuring two women elegy and tragedy
who are indisputably textual entities
embodying contrasting aesthetic and
ideological positions the resemblance
between flirtatious elegy and her flimsy
silks and the flesh-and-blood women naso
pursues elsewhere in the mores implies
in wieck's view that these women are
likewise to be understood not as
specific individuals living in Agustin
Rome but as purely textual entities
signifiers in an authorial message with
an aesthetic : McKean and ideological
ante or para Agustin just this
demystification is moreover the very
burden of the poem quote a mores three
one is designed to mock and entomb the
absurdity of reading amatory poetry as
real while wieck's
textual emphasis has done much to
invigorate invigorate scholarship
analogy I find her argument and the
general line of interpretation
associated with it very hard to accept
there are many degrees and kinds of
reality short of the quasi biographical
referential model specific individuals
on which Wieck seems to be relying the
names Cynthia and Corinna may not denote
particular historical persons but this
does not invalidate the reality effect
such as it is of the poetry in which
they appear contrariwise and this
the point matters most to me here
textual entities are themselves part of
reality with as good a claim to the
label real as mountains and Emperor's a
lot of work on elegy seems to operate on
the assumption that the discovery of a
meta poetic subtext entails the
evacuation of the erotic content as if
poetry and desire occupied entirely
separate spheres as if their relation
could only be metaphorical or
allegorical what I am suggesting is that
the association of the personified
allergy with Karina and her kin
communicates not only the elegiac
woman's essential textuality but also
and conversely the erotic appeal of
writing tragedy is also a form of
writing of course but in a Maurice 3:1
she is associated with the eradication
of lossky weeow at all levels that is
not just nasa's juvenile escapades but
also the in felicitous expansiveness
that constitutes the peculiar Felicity
condition of his unsuccessful rhetorical
performances the impatience conveyed and
tragedies opening salvo will you ever
make an end of loving an interesting
inversion of nasa's reproach the
impassive husband of a Maurice 2:19 is
capped by the impressive gesture with
which she punctuated her speech now she
says let me Roman tragedy gain a name
through your agency your spirit will
meet and match my conditions she stopped
there and resting on her bread or
buskins
moved her head with its thick mane of
hair three times and for haughtiness at
mowett picked ease Enix a Couture nice
den some Chi sari a terra cotta quick
complet this gesture which is patterned
on the cosmic nod of Jupiter belongs to
the mode not of persuasion but of fatal
declaration the speech confirmed by such
a nod must come to pass it is as if
tragedy we're trying to get rid of the
very necessity of rhetoric by erasing
the gap between speech and its effects
in the world now as elegy well
recognizes nothing could be better
calculated to repel naso than such a
posture allergies first repost
accordingly is to replace tragedies
definitive nod with a markedly
quickl gesture the other if memory
serves glanced smiling sideways Altera
seemed M&E lemis Surrey's it
oculus the reticence of LG's clans is
reproduced by the uncertainty in NASA's
recollection see Memon II elegy is
glimpsed through a seductive aura of
doubt the erotic charge is amplified in
the next line
am i deceived or was there a myrtle
staff in her right hand
deception being naturally an essential
seasoning in nasa's affairs it is as if
NASA were experiencing in the present of
writing the shiver of excitement
provoked by elegies arch glance the
thrill of a private communication made
right before tragedies uncomprehending
eyes in effect as john davis has pointed
out elegy seduces nasa by giving him a
delicious swig of his own medicine
making him the audience of an adept
rhetorical performance that he can enjoy
all the more because as her collusive
glance indicates elegy knows from the
start that she has already won the
erotic charge of elegiac rhetoric is
encapsulated in the verb to move a verb
that is equally at home in rhetorical
and erotic contexts according to Cicero
in a formula taken over by quintillion
moving the audience is one of the orders
essential tasks the others being in
giving instruction and giving pleasure
within the Amore's MO where a conjures
up not only the modes of persuasion
directed toward opening the door to
sexual intercourse but also the
intransitive agitations of the sexual
act itself in amorous 1:10 for example
naso argues that he shouldn't have to
pay his partner for sex since this is a
pleasure taken by the woman and the man
moving in concert qualms so kyo mo to
Femina we're quick ferrant
and at the end of 2:10 he hopes that
death will come upon him when he is
engaged in his characteristic activity
the motions of Venus when heurists mo to
which is surely both poetry and sex
right at the middle of book two likewise
when the personified tragedy
pontificates that it is high time na so
be moved or with
simply move under the impulse of a
weightier fiercest tempest era tear so
pull some growl we are a mo weary the
sexual innuendo is so plain as hardly to
count as innuendo whether or not tragedy
is to be imagined as a cross dressed man
like her counterparts on the tragic
stage her rhetoric puts naso in a
position of aconite us a gender deviant
male associated with provocatively
sexual movement can I'd us the word
being associated with Greek Canaan to
move it is as if within the Amore's
where rhetoric never succeeds in moving
anyone the Ciceronian triad had been
compressed and displaced into an
intransitive movement of which the only
effect is pleasure in fact there is an
awful lot of moving going on in a morays
3/1 far more as it happens than in any
other poem in the collection as the poem
opens naso is looking for a work for his
muse to set going quad may acquire a
about moves up mole we're at opus
tragedy auditions for the role by waving
her scepter round away bot and bobbing
her head
mowett all in the interest is we have
seen a persuading not so to move under
the impulsive away or thesis that is an
inspiration more serious than that
supplied by elegy as elegy points out of
the beginning of her response however
for all her weighty words tragedy has
condescended to move or precede an elegy
zone lightweight meter in Paribas Tommen
as numerous Donata mow weary while
Corrina herself has learned from allergy
just slip out of the house at night
without stubbing her toes mo we're at
ped ace given nas's interest in LG's
mismatched feet a metrical pond here is
pretty much inevitable by the end of the
poem the passive senses come to the fore
grant the bar just a bit of time tragedy
naso pleads you our work for the ages
what she asks for is so short and
tragedy a sense mota
dead 'it when IAM though aiming to move
naso tragedy ends up being herself moved
by him this unique instance of
Oracle success is the exception that
proves the rule in that what nassos plea
wins is not admission to the bedroom not
an opportunity to dispense with allergy
but the license to produce more couplets
let me end this paper by letting
allergies speak for herself
unlike tragedies speech allergies speech
is full of surprises
after some disarming self-depreciation I
wouldn't venture to compare your sublime
poetry with mine and so on
elegy precedes to make a case for
herself it is she who as the BOD and
companion of Venus renders love
civilised and is she who educated Karina
in the ways of furtive love but the real
reason she deserves to have sway she
says and here I'm following Kenny's
slightly transposed text is that she has
put up with humiliations to which proud
tragedy could never submit lines 53 to
58 how often I hung fixed to an
unyielding door unabashed at being read
by people passing by I even remembered
lurking miserably in the folds of a
slave's dress waiting for the brutal
chaperone to leave and what about when
you send me as a birthday present and
the girl tears me up the savage and
drowns me in water she had on hand the
downward trajectory is very dramatic and
it is accelerated by the evaporation of
the personification she who entered the
poem in the in the guise of a beguiling
woman the bosom companion of Venus is
reduced by the end of this passage to
mere paper and this paper has its own
degradation to suffer passing from the
door where can be read by all and sundry
to the hiding place where it lurks in
hopes of a single secret reader to the
water basin which it forfeits the very
possibility of legibility Alessandra
burrkc has observed that off it is
perhaps the most daring of ancient poets
in personifying texts and animating
books and it's remarkable combination of
personification and animation elegy as
muse and elegy as talking book roll this
passage is more daring than most of
course elegies very ability to chronicle
her own misadventures indicates that she
has outlived them she is not after all
fully present in any particular
material instance of her text so this
moment of degradation may also serve to
confirm allergies and destructibility
just as naso predicts at the end of the
first book of memorize that he will in
large part survive the funeral pyre
so elegy demonstrates that she has
survived the utter obliteration
inflicted on her material corpus by
dismemberment and drowning even so what
comes next is a surprise from the nadir
of the water basin elegy vaults to the
high ground even the highest ground I
was the first to set your minds fertile
seeds in motion it is my gift to you
that she is pursuing you now
elegy ends by identifying herself as not
the material product but the original
source of NASA's inspiration not the
gift but the giver I am most struck by
line 59 prima - I'm oh we fail akia's
Sammy no mentis
the language here is overwhelmingly
philosophical conjuring up annex a giris
who held that the world was made of
seeds set in motion by mind along with
Aristotle who likewise identified mind
as the prime mover you know Prima - I'm
Oh oui and also Lucretia's who argue
contrary wise that mind men's was itself
composed of very tiny seeds but elegies
sublime argument cannot be boxed up so
far as I can judge within any existing
philosophical theory the motion she
produces in NASA's mind fuses creative
ferment with erotic excitement a
prototypically na Sounion combination
thank you